Growing
questions about
the destruction of a critical dam along
the front lines in Ukraine.
We've got new video in to OUTFRONT.
This is a building being swept away
as the floodwaters
just completely raced across the terrain.
Now, Ukraine had warned
that if the dam ever was compromised,
nearly
5 billion gallons of water
would flood southern Ukraine.
That's equivalent to the Great Salt
Lake in Utah.
And one Ukrainian officer tells CNN
that his men watched Russian soldiers
actually being swept away.
So let me just show you where this dam is
to give you a sense of it right here
along the crucial Dnieper River
and rail on the front line of this war.
Russia is has been control of one side,
Ukraine on the other nearby.
Of course, is Europe's largest
nuclear power plant in separate Georgia,
which relies on the water
in this reservoir to cool its reactors.
And Ukraine is blaming Russia tonight
This is
deliberate destruction
of the dam and other facilities
by the Russian occupiers
is an environmental bomb.
Of mass destruction.
For the sake of their own security,
the world should now show that Russia
will not get away with such terror.
Russia denies it and blaming Ukraine.
The United States is still investigating
it, says, according to intelligence.
Earlier, Zelensky's,
senior adviser, spoke to OUTFRONT,
and he said
the attack
was to stop Ukraine's
highly anticipated counteroffensive.
Right.
Which had been
the whole goal
was to cross the Dnipro River.
The United States, of course, believes
that counteroffensive has begun.
Here's Alinsky's adviser, Mikhail Polack.
Russia begin blowing up the
hydropower plant.
Russia is trying to suspend
our counteroffensive,
in this case in the southern direction,
but cannot give them enough.
Fred Pleitgen is OUTFRONT to
begin our coverage in the flooded region.
Masses of water
gushing from the gaping
hole in the destroyed
Nova Kafka Dam
in Russian controlled territory.
Here in south Ukraine,
massive flooding quickly
inundating villages
on both shores of the mighty Dnipro
River, impacting areas
controlled by Ukrainians
and by the Russians.
As you can see,
there's a massive rescue effort
going on here.
Local authorities are using boats
and also heavy trucks
to get as many people
as out of the zone as they can.
With at least 65 year old Nadezhda
Cerna Chauvin
was stranded in her home
with her cat, Sonja, for hours
fearing for her life.
To, you know,
we just by now, I'm not scared, she says.
But there it was scary.
Why, I ask?
Because of the water the water came in.
You don't know from where it comes
and where it go right away.
The authorities here
say they've evacuated hundreds of people
throughout the day
at times under Russian fire.
The head of her son's
military administration
tells me he would not stay here.
We have the water, he says.
Mines mines are floating to here.
And this district is constantly
being shelled.
Two policemen were injured
while evacuating people still on.
Kiev blames Moscow for
allegedly blowing up the dam.
An angry Ukrainian president
saying the Russians are trying to
derail Ukraine's
current battlefield game.
It's America.
It was mined by the Russian occupiers,
he says. And they blew it up.
This once again demonstrates
the cynicism
with which Russia treats the people
whose land it has captured.
Them to Zuckerberg for
the destruction
of the dam comes
as Ukrainian forces
have been making gains
on the battlefield,
what some believe may be
the early stages of Kiev's
long awaited counteroffensive.
Even though the Ukrainians
haven't confirmed that
Russia's army
denies blowing up the dam,
instead blaming the Ukrainians
selling the pressure
of aiming to prevent
the offensive operations
by the Russian army.
On the section of the front line,
the Kiev regime
committed an act of sabotage
or rather a terrorist act,
the defense minister said.
While the floodwaters are
affecting ever more areas
around here,
sun upstream,
the levels are critically low.
Around the Zakariya Power Plant,
the biggest in all of Europe,
which relies on a pond
connected to the river for cooling.
The International Atomic Energy
Agency says so far there's no danger,
but that could change.
It is therefore vital
that these cooling pond,
these cooling ponds remains intact.
Nothing must be done
to potentially undermine its integrity
so that you can see here
an extremely difficult
and dangerous situation
down here in the south of Ukraine
with that massive river
just continuously flooding.
And I think there's two things
that our viewers
really need to be aware of.
On the one hand,
those floodwaters are rising
extremely quickly.
We were on the ground there today.
And just in a short period of time,
that water went up considerably.
And the other thing is,
the Russian army is very close
to this place.
There is constant shelling going on here.
In fact,
as I'm speaking to you right now.
I'm hearing those thuds in the distance.
And this comes
as Ukrainian
officials are saying they believe
that more than a thousand
houses are underwater
just in the Ukrainian
two full territories of the flood
zone Erin. Fred, thank you very much.
Live in her son
in the midst of that flooding, as you
and you could
hear him saying,
you hear the thuds of the shelling
in the distance and it stops.
And joins me now,
a member of Ukraine's parliament.
And then I appreciate your time.
Obviously, I know it is very late
where you are very early in the morning.
Does Ukraine have proof
that Russia is responsible
for the dam explosion and break
Well, of course, we
cannot provide a very specific proof
because the dam has been
under Russian control for months now.
And I think that is the single proof
that we can provide
is that the dam is under Russian control.
The explosion came from within.
So it had to be done
by someone
who had control over the territory
and that those are the Russians
who had the control over the territory.
They were the only ones
who could have actually done this.
So so this is as much evidence
as we can provide,
given that
we do not have access
to this territory now
and we didn't have access
to this territory yesterday
to set up such an explosion.
All right.
Well, it's crucial
that everyone understand that.
I think these are important facts.
A senior Naito official
and I said today that U.S.
and Western officials do see signs that
the long awaited
counteroffensive against
Russia is beginning Obviously,
when you're talking about 5 billion
gallons of water now flooding a region.
Does the dam break,
do you think, have any impact
on the counteroffensive plans
Well, it is
definitely distracting our military,
at least. Right?
People who could have been engaged
in the counteroffensive efforts
are now doing evacuation and now helping
with people
with the humanitarian aid
and so on and so forth.
So that is the least effect
that it can have on the counteroffensive.
Now, as you know very well
as of right now,
that the
detailed plan
of the counteroffensive is unclear.
So we cannot confirm
or deny
that this could have been
the direction of the counteroffensive.
But the fact that it definitely
diverts efforts
from the military side
to the humanitarian aid,
which is also being provided
by the military personnel
on the south over there right now.
That is definitely can be confirmed.
So, yes, I can say that it is
part of the plan
to to suspend the counteroffensive.
Whether it will be successful or not,
I think the coming days will show.
All right.
And of course, the world is watching.
And I thank you so very much.
I appreciate your time. Thank.